how does trigonometry actually mean in
Greek this red part means triangle and
the blue part means measure trigonometry
is one of the most feared topics in
mathematics but in reality it is
extremely simple
the meaning itself is so simple it's
just the measure of all the things
possible in a triangle that's all let's
consider a triangle ABC let a be the
length of the side opposite angle a and
similarly let b and c be the length of
the sides opposite angles B and C
respectively take a close look at the
triangle what all can be measured in
this triangle we can measure the angles
angle a angle B and angle C or find the
lengths of the sides which in this case
are a B and C these are the only six
things we deal with in trigonometry
three sides and three angles out of
these six we are given a few and using
trigonometry we need to find the rest
it cannot be difficult actually it gets
a bit simpler as trigonometry generally
deals with only one kind of triangle a
right-angled triangle which is also
referred to as a right triangle this
right triangle is right angled at this
vertex the good news is that one angle
is known and only two remain this one
and this one let this angle be theta
this is the triangle we will be dealing
with to cover most of our trigonometry a
triangle with an angle theta and a right
angle it doesn't have to be called theta
but that's what it is generally referred
to as but these kind of triangles help
us in real-life
how does trigonometry help us in real
life let's say Zen wants to find the
height of this tree he has to measure
this length which is the height one way
is to make an approximate
but a better way to find the height is
by using trigonometry let's assume this
distance is known to us remember it's
always easier to find the distance or
the length on the ground than finding
the distance vertically and we can find
the approximate measure of this angle
which is Theta with just these two
pieces of information then can find the
height of this tree
finding the height of a tree may not
sound appealing to you but the next
example surely will this time then wants
to find the height of a mountain if this
distance is known and this angle is
known then the height can easily be
found out but how that's precisely what
we will try to understand in
trigonometry